when I tried to read mathematics it  would take an hour a page and I'd get  some of the ideas but not others and  usually it would be six months later  that suddenly it would click and so I  think guys thought of myself as sort of  slow but I never grew up in some sense  and as far as I can tell I've been  getting better at things slowly and  steadily it was only when I was older  that I noticed that most people do  something wonderful and then they get  stuck and I started to make theories of  why do people get stuck and how to avoid  it and the best thing is to if you've  done something you should be ashamed of  it instead of proud of it and I notice a  lot of people keep saying well I thought  of that a long time ago and and they  keep trying to get recognition and why  bother